- So we were searching for
weed shops on Washington Boulevard.
(soft music)
- Well, we got my Google search history
all loaded up and my father here is gonna
take a look.
- You've been workin' on
a lot of stuff for school
so it should be a lot of
stuff about that, right?
- She's a weirdo, so, everything she does
is a weird thing to do.
- I'm gonna start from the top.
- Le sex--
- No.
- Paris.
- No, that's Le Six.
- You are not going to Burning Man.
I don't even know why
you're looking that up.
- Oh my god.
- Andro-gy-nus?
(laughing)
- Androgynous.
- There you go.
(laughing)
- [Stephanie] Yay.
Okay.
(laughing)
- Lil Wayne's baby mama.
How much money Floyd
Mayweather made at the fight.
It was a lot.
Does Kim really love Kanye?
You are nosy.
The computer cannot tell you
if Kim really loves Kanye.
- What's this one?
- A first aid kid.
- A first aid kit, okay.
- Why'd I need that?
- Why did you need a first aid kit?
- I don't know.
This is actually more exciting for myself.
I love to like go back and see what I --
- Relive.
- Relive my life here.
- Antonio Banderas.
- Us Mexicans need to
represent in the media.
- He's not a Mexican guy.
- He's not?
I should go to you instead of Google.
- So we were searching for
weed shops on Washington Boulevard.
- How to cook pasta.
(laughing)
You boil water.
- Where are you?
You had to Google where you were?
- Nicki Minaj, Anaconda, Stephanie?
- The music video is
just booties everywhere.
(laughing)
- You still lookin' up Spongebob things?
- Oh my god, dad, it was a gif.
- From who?
Who gave it to you?
(laughing)
- We went from Tinder,
and now we're on Bumble.
- It's an app, it's a
dating app called Bumble.
- Yeah.
- I think Bumble's a lot better.
- Okay and how about, what's this?
Bad hygiene habits.
Why would you be Googling
bad hygiene habits?
So you can do them?
- I was just--
- I mean, so you can do them?
- No, I can see if my
habits matched up to that,
then I don't have a problem.
- How many steps does it
take to walk to Mexico?
From here?
From right here?
- From LA.
- From LA?
- This is amazing.
I am blown away by this stuff here.
Now what's this?
Seven types of boys you might wanna meet.
- When does my inmate get out of men's--
Wait.
- When does my inmate get out of--
- When does my inmate get
out of men's central jail?
- Okay.
- What was that?
Wait, what was that?
- And then you have here,
how to hide email addresses.
What's this, Adam?
- What?
- How to hide email addresses.
- Oh, okay, okay, okay.
- Wait a minute.
- No, no, no, no, no.
- I really don't remember.
- Do you know somebody in jail?
- No.
- Okay?
- Hold on, hold up.
- I caught you red-handed.
- Sponsoring?
Are you sponsoring somebody I know?
Yeah, sure they aren't.
- Hold up, remember when
I sent out the newsletter?
- Uh huh.
- I needed to figure out
how to make it anonymous.
- That's cool uh huh.
Sure, Adam.
- Yeah, yeah, you just put it in the BCC.
- Definitely, I learned
that she's a weirdo.
But she's my daughter, so.
(laughing)
- I need to do this more often.
- I think you don't, to be honest.
- Thanks for lettin'
me look at your emails.
- Well.
- Or your search history.
- My search history.
- But, next time you'll
delete some of those things.
- Yeah.
- Delete your histories.
(laughing)
Especially for things you
don't want anyone to see.
Don't worry, I did that
and everything was cool.
- You did?
- Of course I did.
You think that's all I search?
(upbeat music)